being creative and doing stuff stuff at
a very Grassroots level and trying to
grow a company we make cool stuff in a
cool industry race car driver Ken Block
has died following a snowmobile accident
in Utah he was 55 years old I don't know
I've been really lucky in that way that
I like really rich content and I like
making really in-depth stories around
athletes doing rad stuff that's just an
amazing feeling block who co-founded the
skateboard brand DC Shoes shared this
photo to his Instagram story hours
before his death on Sunday he captioned
the image sketchy and snowy Drive
block often shared videos of himself
snowmobiling to social media I grew up
on the weekends going up into the
mountains enjoying just the mountains
themselves in the summer and then the
snow in the winter and in a statement
post to Facebook the Wasatch County
Sheriff's Office said block was on a
steep slope when his snowmobile upended
landing on top of him and he is
pronounced dead at the scene I knew I
needed to just drive conservative drive
clean now the sports world's paying
tribute Tony Hawk shared this pic to
Instagram when the pair went
snowboarding in Utah a year ago Hawk
writes Ken was a Pioneer with talents
that transcended our world bringing
skate fashion into the mainstream and
helping legitimize rally car culture
through his Peerless driving the
skateboard Legend adds a video of Ken
from that day and sadly Hawk says it was
the last time he saw his friend of three
decades Ken dropped into unknown
territory with speed Grace and
confidence thanks for showing us the way
in recent years block was best known for
Motorsports
and videos of his exploits racked up
millions of views on YouTube well the
first time I got in a race car I
absolutely loved it and it was it was
everything I dreamed about as a kid you
know driving for the first time it was
incredible and I was like okay when do I
get back in the car next like I was
hooked Block's company Hoon again shared
a statement following his death Ken was
a Visionary a Pioneer and an icon and
most importantly father and husband
block is survived by his wife and three
children